I don't know the Muslim word for hutzpah
but the family of yesterday's failed New
York bomber is full of it
they're attacking law enforcement for
so-called heavy-handed tactics what say
you New York chapter the Council on
american-islamic relations I bet you're
outraged
we are also outraged by the behavior of
the law enforcement officials who have
held children as small as four years old
out in the cold and who pulled a
teenager out of high school classes to
interrogate him without a lawyer without
his parents the children they put
children out in the cold which can
happen when you take them outside
briefly to a waiting car and I'm sure
the teen jerked out of high school was
heartbroken
he was probably busy in shop class
building a clock but it's a common
reflex use kids as a defense clearly
it's not about the terror attack at all
but about the children but they're right
we shouldn't be questioning the family
we should be putting them up in a
five-star hotel with nothing but the
best food in entertainment maybe tickets
to a show tried Book of Mormon you get a
kick out of that or why not visit the
Freedom Tower for a guided tour Keira
also said this these are not the sorts
of actions we expect from our justice
system
well terrorism is not the sort of thing
we expect from decent law-abiding humans
but yeah it's our justice system we got
to worry about so I offer this humble
suggestion to the family it's the
justice system that is protecting you
from your own family member so you
should not only thank these officers but
also you should cooperate because if
this were any other country including
the one that you left family members of
a terrorist would be collected and
probably never heard from again but I
guess that's why you're here for now
Dana tone-deaf response from them yeah a
reflexive response I mean you see this
across especially in the UK where there
honestly I understand their concern
right but their reflex is to use our
system against us right and to say oh
you were doing something bad to us like
well no actually the police are worried
about children too which is exactly why
they came to try to find it
because the police are in a race against
time yeah because what if there was
something coordinated what if somebody
knew that there was actually multiple
bombs that were being made in the house
and they were fanned out across the city
and so time is of the essence and our
law enforcement deserves our full
support you know Kimberly Oh Dave
they're concerned about the safety of
the family too
they got to get the they don't want that
kid to be beaten up or whatever they're
I mean they're that's their their
priority is to make sure everybody is
taken to a safe place and they could be
questioned what's wrong with that well
there isn't anything wrong with it
obviously but this is kind of the tactic
that they do this is just really kind of
like the book they go by the book say
okay we're gonna attack law enforcement
we're gonna attack the American justice
system we're gonna find any way we can
to find fault with it to distract and
deflect and flip the script on them to
say that this is really about an
injustice being committed against the
terrorists but is anybody really buying
this besides care because this is what
they do it's why they don't have any
credibility and they go ahead and their
sympathizers for terrorists and for
jihad and their enablers and I have no
time for it watch of the should the law
apologize to the family I don't you know
I was when I was first started I thought
well what did they do yeah did they hurt
somebody
they beat somebody up too you know I
mean to my mind we live in a country
where you just have to take your hat off
I mean I think of the situation we're in
that what the guy was from New Jersey
and he was found it would be up to I
forget exactly what the attack was maybe
was here Times Square and you know they
took him to the hospital yeah the chap
was at the Chelsea attack I'm not sure
no I don't think I'm not sure but anyway
my point is that guy gets yeah
first-rate world-class medical yeah same
thing with this guy this guy's in the
hospital yeah and I think that you're
right there are a lot of places where
you know savage human reaction would
would rule the day not in the USA thank
God yeah that's true so when they said
this I thought well did they were they
roughhousing the family or did they
rouse them out of there and you know
when they say they took a child out yeah
I'd and it's I think it's 40 degrees
yesterday yeah yeah come on I know Jesse
did you see the I guess the terrorists
had posted comments about Trump on
Facebook yes he was taunting the
president yes exactly said thank you for
you you failed to protect America yeah
good one buddy any
so set off the bombs because he was
offended by a bunch of Christmas
placards near the train station - so the
guy is just so ungrateful and we've seen
this a lot of these bombers they come
here on a lottery system or through some
immigration loophole they get here
they're either receiving welfare food
stamps sometimes they get freedom of
speech freedom of worship freedom of
expression yet they hate this country so
much they want to attack it and care is
probably the worst PR that American
Muslims could have if I had a family
member they came into another country
tried to set off a bomb and then he got
busted literally red-handed I would
apologize hide and then cooperate but
instead they send care out to read a
statement to undermine law enforcement
and to prod try to play the victim card
if they had set off a bomb in Bangladesh
where they're cut there came from I'm
sure the law enforcement would have been
a little more aggressive yeah I was
watching Rick Levin thought I did a
little fact I didn't know that the guy
actually used Christmas lights in the in
in the making of the bomb war on
Christmas your system you can't get it
out of longest war it's the longest war
ever